hey guys came here with news that fable
legends is going to be free to play for
all the nitty-gritty details find out in
this free to play Jesus news updates
however if you want me in a different
character skin though that is going to
cost you this really your money that's
right the upcoming 4v1 multiplayer
action RPG prequel is launching as a
free-to-play game or Windows 10 and Xbox
one initially players will have access
to season 1 content consisting of a
traditional linear RPG storyline and
side quests along with four heroes to
play as those who choose to play as a
villain will have a range of different
creatures to command which are tied into
the game's narrative so how exactly does
the model work welp developer line head
of turn two games like League of Legends
dota 2 and Team Fortress for fable
legends business model and they promised
that players will be able to experience
the entire game for free speaking to
gain spot product manager Ian Griffiths
explains why they chose to go that
direction they're very commercially
successful they're well loved by the
players and we want to be in that kind
of area when you fall in love with a
game and it's just such a great
experience you get to that point where
you want to invest in it that means no
gated areas open access to old quests
and no energy bar to limit playtime the
only thing that will stand in your way
from playing quest 7 is that you haven't
finished quest 6 explained game director
David Eckelberry just like your
traditional RPG storyline is mostly
linear with some cyclists so all of you
have open access to all the quests in
all of the seasons that we ever do so
what are the long-term plans for fable
legends well lion-headed promising a
regular stream of updates that will
include new quests heroes creatures and
items all of which will be free for both
xbox one and Windows 10 users most
importantly echo very stressed to any
items directly affecting gameplay can be
earned organically via the game's chest
and loot system he also stressed to XP
and resources like potions cannot be
bought now of course fable legends will
encourage players to make purchases even
if those items can also be earned
through gameplay the four heroes you can
play as for example will rotate on a
round of for nightly basis and a new set
of public face
characters will be introduced any XP and
loot aren't with those characters will
be saved until the next appear in the
public rotation though however users
will also be able to purchase that
character for yeast indefinitely either
by using silver coins collected during
gameplay or by forking over real-world
cash what we don't know so far however
is exactly how much play time will be
needed in order to earn enough coins to
purchase a character we haven't really
arrived what that time is griffith said
the best we can say is that if you're
playing the game a decent amount as we
expect a game or two it would be
reasonable to assume that you don't lock
the character so what do you make of
fable legends adopting this free-to-play
business model are you excited or are
you worried it might become pay to win
let me know in the comments down below
and for all your other news and more
details about fable legends make sure
you go on over to gamespot com